mike
one okay there we go okay we're live
streaming here so be advised people are
watching maybe they're not but they
could be anyways
and if you want to speak please uh uh
use the mic uh this is a work session
on hb 1258 which is relative to the
implementation of the department of
energy
um we have a subcommittee and what we're
trying to do here is not necessarily
solve every possible
wrong or perceived wrong with uh h with
the way the thing is set up right now
but try to correct the things that we've
recognized that came out of hb2 they're
not working necessarily or may not work
uh i think this reorganization thing
between the puc and the department of
energy is probably going to have another
round next year when we have some more
time in and see actually what works and
what doesn't work because you know as of
right now a lot of these positions have
only been filled for a couple of months
so we're still having a lot of uh
which way should we go so what my point
is we're not trying to solve every issue
that we possibly can address in the
subcommittee otherwise we would be here
for the next six weeks which i don't
know about you but i don't want to do uh
so anyways i was going to start
by we i have
and make sure we don't have something
else i have three sets of uh proposed
comments one came from
uh
one came from the department and the
commission
and i'd like to start with them uh they
have a couple of issues that they still
apparently disagree on but they were
supposedly working on and since i was
sailing around the caribbean and mostly
underwater whenever i could be
uh in the last week
i didn't really have a chance to follow
up on them so i guess we'll leave it to
david and griffin if you guys want to
come up and tell us where we're at with
uh let me just say i hopefully i believe
everyone on the subcommittee should have
got a copy of their comments
which uh starts out okay here's a little
bit more now okay well we'll go with
they did tell me cat that they were
going to be working on trying to come up
with more over the last week but like i
said i was kind of out of sell range of
email range so this appears to be the
latest so we'll let them address that
gentlemen
go ahead and just remember to turn on
your mics
uh thank you uh representative
harrington for the record griffin
roberge from the department of energy
david shulock from the department of
energy
so we just passed out a new list this is
the same list that you saw last month
with some changes
right so
one of the
disagreements if you want to call it
that between the
it was a discussion really between the
puc and the department
had to do with community power
aggregation and which agency
uh should uh have the authority over
that under rsa 53e excuse me could you
reference which number uh this is
referring to
number four which is stricken on on this
uh on the new list
cliff below made a comment about that
thinking that they thought that perhaps
the puc was the appropriate body
the department and the puc discussed
that and the department has decided to
withdraw
so that you know all of that authority
would remain with the public utilities
commission
let's uh let's make this as informal as
possible because it is a work session so
sure david could you do that please
um
and
you know we can do this one of two ways
we can go through the bill the amendment
itself or we can go through the
department's list your
preference what do uh subcommittee
members prefer
would you prefer just to go through the
list as it's written okay then that
we can look at the bill afterwards if
jackie please use your microphone
i'm having a very hard time hearing him
i don't know if the microphone isn't
closer that he said and i thought it i
heard him say that he the department was
going to withdraw
all their requests to um
it was just online item four or the
newest thing that they passed out there
was the question of community
was that
so it's going to stay with the puc
is what they're saying that was that
it's going to stay that but you had
requested that it be gone from the pc
and now you've
acceded that it should be in a piece
okay that's all i wanted a clarification
huh yeah so david maybe you can just
start from the top of the list and go
through with that please uh so the first
one is a uh request to amend uh the
state's
crossing license statute
so
you know there there's a provision in
the statute that allows public utilities
to commence eminent domain proceedings
so that they can cross people's private
lands right and then there's a section
of that statute for the crossing of
public lands and public waters because
public utilities and regular companies
that want to run utility type lines
can't conduct eminent domain upon the
state
right okay so there's a provision in
that statute
that allowed the puc
to grant
licenses to public utilities and
individuals running public utility type
lines or pipes across state land to give
house bill 2 divided that authority
between
the department
and the puc
but that division was clunky
in in in the way that it worked right
clunky in the sense that
you know both the
department and then the public utilities
commission had to open adjudicative
proceedings to do that
right
um what we would be requesting is that
the department be permitted to grant
those licenses
for
for utilities to cross state lands and
state waters to have that just be
an administrative process
at the department
unless some
some person who's affected by that
crossing feels harmed
and wants to appeal it to the puc
that's a big reversal
isn't it
so
my understanding is that that would be a
regulatory process so the regulatory
process is now being moved over to
what we were
discussing during hb2 discussions as a
bright red line right we're taking
regulatory
processes for
facilities
energy facilities being cited over
public lands and giving it to
uh
an agency rather than
regulators right that's a big change
there the the authority um has existed
at the public utilities commission to
grant those licenses for a very long
time yep right so house
house bill 2
divided that authority that was a big
change
when they created the department and
divided the authority to grant those
licenses
and the way that it was divided was that
the
department was permitted to grant a
license when all of the parties agreed
right
but
we we have to establish an adjudicative
process to find out even who the parties
are
right
and that's a very clunky process so what
we're proposing
is that we
review the license application
grant it or deny it
give give everybody notice
of that and then people who want to
actually adjudicate whether they've
suffered a monetary damage as a result
of that crossing or they think there's
some some aesthetic problem with the
crossing that they can take then take
that over to the puc and adjudicate it
okay so
i've had a lot of experience with these
crossings um
very very few of them
are controversial
or
they're very few are controversial right
they're granted all the time by the
public utilities commission with nobody
from the public ever wanting to to
participate
right so
representative votes
mr shulock would it not be true that
making this change would speed up this
entire process but not making it would
make it
slower and more cumbersome
that's correct this is an efficiency
measure thank you
peter i believe you had a question thank
you mr shulock
since you're saying that
the original proposal was too clunky
it wouldn't be the simplest thing just
to leave it with the puc that's probably
the least clunky of all
uh
basically because the puc doesn't have
the staff to
to accomplish the task and that is a
result of the reorganization so that is
not a great excuse but that's that's
where we're at one thing i want my
people understand on this so just
there's no confusion because it is an
important piece this is not talking
about private land crossings okay that's
eminent domain and it's very strict
rules on that a lot of people have said
a lot of things about it with some
transmission projects how we say unnamed
that would never have made that uh never
have crossed that
uh bar because it was too high it has to
be that's very difficult when you're
talking private this is on public lands
like a bridge going across a river where
i when the last one i think i was
involved was a gas pipeline down in
newington and nobody really cared the
gas pipeline was there but they were
moving it because they put up a new
bridge and the whole process went
through and it just becomes more
cumbersome because you have to have an
adjudicative process where there was no
one adjudicating against it but you had
to go through all you had to almost
pretend there was somebody there that
wasn't and it just would make it a lot
simpler but that does leave the option
if somebody does really have a concern
over again only public only talking
about public crossings here so if they
say well i don't want to have to look at
that gas pipeline
then they can appeal to the puc and
bring in lawyers and have the full
hearing and the whole bit can i get the
definition of public lands
does that include conservation lands and
open space and what is included in that
it includes lands owned by the state of
new hampshire just the state right um we
do although the
puc and the doe do not regulate
crossings over
highways
the department of transportation deals
i'm just going to say two words great
um
how
when you make this decision or grant
this license
do you bring in the very same people
that the puc would have brought in in
other words will you have hearings on it
will you have
uh department you know environmental
services and any other departments that
need to be brought in or is this a
totally internal process
so the the process at the department
would be internal
people who were affected by it
right who who might want to
litigate against it
would litigate at the puc
on the basis of a license that was
issued or denied
so after the fact
before anything was constructed right
but after the license work was granted
with and under the proposal the puc
could order the department to withdraw
the license modify the license or if the
department denied a license order the
department to grant the license
but but it doesn't
exempt anybody from other
permits that they may have by law on
whether it's des or anybody else they'd
still have exactly correct and the case
i was talking about jackie was actually
the pipeline going across great bay well
now we have transmission lines but i i
i
is
if somebody came in and
wanted to construct
something across a public order way
how does the public know that that even
might happen do you notify will the
department of exchange
notify that we're kind of
going this is an area that hasn't
changed they're still going to this the
notifications and all that stuff is
going to stick with the law if we get
into that level of detail on every
single thing we're going to be here
you're going to be here for a long time
to find out
what the change for the next 25 years is
going to be but that hasn't changed
they're still going to do the public
notification requirements that exist
that existed 10 years ago that existed
10 days ago that will exist
10 years from now so no one's talking
about changing that right so under under
the proposal that we would give you
permit was granted or denied the
department would publish notice on its
website and then has the ability to
direct the public utility to publish
that notice in a newspaper or on its
website
and then if it's actually appealed
then there's another requirement that
the public utilities commission
give its regular notice
of that appeal proceeding so that if
other people want to come in and
litigate against or for the crossing
they can do that
so
yeah thank you
i understand that the poc is now
understaffed to be able to do this but
seems to me if people can appeal to the
puc and that organization doesn't have
the staff
that will become a very uh tough thing
to do or it will be a drawn out thing to
do you must just get rid of the appeal
to the puc entirely
because if you're trying to speed up the
process in the appeal let me could i
address that david please because what's
going to happen there is you're
basically going to have the department
of energy shaking we think this permit
should be granted and they're going to
have staff and present a case to the puc
and you're going to have somebody else
who's saying we don't agree so the puc
is not going to be an investigative body
they're going to be an adjudicative body
much like a judge in a court case
they're going to sit there and listen to
both sides and decide what is right they
don't need their own research and to
quite then i see clifton over there
nodding his head because i can remember
being told a bunch of times as a puc
commissioner knock it off because i
would do my own research and they say
you can only pay attention to what's
presented at the hearing that's the
facts that's what you have to base your
decision on so that's not really an
issue
okay
and we we have heard from
utilities at least that some of the
processes were cumbersome
for them
he said it's informal you can just go
okay
back back when we were discussing
these bills sb91 and three foot
we were told that this was going to be a
cost saver because they were they're
going to eliminate redundant staff and
where it was needed the staff would be
made available to whichever group needed
it you know like they were going to
share the you know
human resources and share the legal
staff and share these diff is that like
no longer on the table now there's a
wall and the
doe staff cannot be made available to
the puc as needed
that's a very
packed question
so
um
there is a provision in the statute
which we're asking you to change
right that
prohibited any employee from the
department speaking with any employee at
the puc
or vice versa
regarding any matter pending before the
other
right
and that has
really put up a wall
when it comes to
cooperation
among the two agencies to achieve the
efficiencies
that i think the bill was designed to
achieve
and we have some language
that will hopefully resolve that
then in addition to that the two
agencies are working together sort of
behind the scenes
on memorandum of understanding of how to
without talking to each other
well there's no matter pending on that
talking about how to cooperate with one
another generally
maybe i need to move
for example we had the energy storage
docket where there was a report and it
was being written we were all all the
way to you know ground zero and it was
yo
it was about to be issued and that's
that was like august of last year right
what you can't talk to each other
because it's a pending matter
well we we can't talk to each other
behind the scenes on that docket we talk
to each other on the record
and and our meetings going on on the
record if you don't
know
that those meetings would involve all
the parties if they were occurring
that's what i'm i'm a part of it if
you'd like to know so here for a second
what they have is they call technical
sessions and they'll have the various
all the different interveners and people
and i have participated in every single
one of them i know
and they'll they'll they can sit down
and talk but they are on the record yeah
there's the you have the whole ex party
thing that you have to be careful of
especially with the commissioners
because they're not allowed to have
private conversations even though again
clifton's nodding his head over there
because i don't know how many phone
calls we got from a particular um
executive council member uh
and that we just couldn't talk to him so
i mean that's that's the way it is so
the technical sessions do allow them to
talk to each other because everybody's
there and it's public so if if we were
having substantive discussions about one
of the dockets
all of the parties would get notice
and i would be able to participate or
you might find it you might see it in a
letter filed in the docket
so that you know that that conversation
occurred and that or was occurring and
you could respond to it
so if you're not saying it it's not
happening
can we move on to uh item two here
okay um so
on number two okay a number of years ago
house bill i think it was 1104
was passed to shorten the amount of time
that agencies had
to respond to applications and requests
right
um at that time a number of agencies
came in and asked the
uh legislature for exemptions to those
timelines they were essentially cut in
half right
back
when 1104 went through
number of agencies came in and asked for
exceptions
um des got a
great number of those
the public utilities commission
got exemptions for
practically well i won't even say
practically for everything that the
public utilities commission did
and
i think the reason for that is because
there's virtually nothing that occurs
at the public utilities commission that
does not involve
an uninformed
rate payer
who's having a problem
right
and so
many of the things that the public
utilities commission does
take a lot of time it takes some hand
holding
some helping the ratepayer communicate
with their public utility and vice versa
to make sure that matters are resolved
doing that in the short amount of time
is often not
possible
then in addition you know you have
normal
people
putting solar panels on their homes and
they have to negotiate some very
complicated rules
when they do that
and have to file applications about
they're not expert in right and
very often
uh the information that they provide is
wrong
and has to be traced through and has to
be corrected
those things also
are difficult to do within the short
amount of time provided by the statute
then
a number of the requests that would go
to the commission really aren't suitable
for automatic grant
right and that that is the hammer uh in
541a if you don't meet the timeline then
the request is automatically granted
right
uh the request might be something like
would you please
require my utility to give me a payment
plan i can afford
well
what does it mean if that's
automatically granted
right well you you just don't know right
um
then there are a number of
things that would go before the
commission that are are delicate such as
terminations of service
and especially when those terminations
occur
when somebody has a medical condition
and they require the utility service
so that they don't die or have some
serious event
um
when when their utilities are are cut
off right
um and those are also very time
consuming involve a lot of investigation
making sure that the utility has gone
out and given all the proper notices and
banged on the door and tried to get
somebody in person etc david if i can
just interrupt for a second so what
we're basically doing is saying the same
rule that would apply to the puc is now
going to apply to doe correct that's
okay the reason for that is like he
stated is um i remember there was two
cases i'll mention there was one in that
house in bedford that went on for a year
and a half maybe longer this guy had all
sorts of mystery stuff going on in his
house and he was blaming the utility for
it and there was another one in bed in
the north country and it took us a long
time to get this power turned off when
they actually turned it off they found
he had like 150 pinball machines that
were on all the time and that's why his
bill was so high yeah but i mean these
things just they don't allow themselves
to be adjudicated really fast sometimes
and this just all it does is transfer
the authority that the puc has now to
the commission which will be
implementing that there's no change in
that
yeah i you know i hear i love i love
that story but i also remember the story
about the woman who froze to death in
her home because her utilities have been
shut off and that that's obviously
something that none of us want to have
happen again and that was what we tried
to avoid and that hit me deeply so if
i give you the date
don't understand
if
the doe makes a decision oh we're
cutting that off
where does a customer go
if there's a timeline
to appeal that
do they go to the puc to appeal that
decision or they go to you to appeal
that decision or they go to the supreme
court i mean i i i
that's the thing i don't understand
i think under the statutes they would
first come back to us
back to you um and then they would
i've asked the attorney general's office
to look into this i haven't gotten an
answer yet but i think it's the supreme
court after that
so
so if i clarify in my head
the puc will have nothing to do
as far as adjudicating
that position
whether it you know your decision it
would then go straight to attorney
general perhaps
subject to check i believe that's true
okay
supreme court you mean not the attorney
general
that would be the appellate uh
jurisdiction right and and most people
who can't pay a bill can't afford to go
to the supreme court right
isn't that really complicated that
something as trivial as cutting off
power i mean not trivial in the sense
that it could do harm but as trivial as
a process
that people have to go to the supreme
court for this
i think they did anyhow
i know but it's the same now peter it's
if you
write well two years ago if you went to
the puc and they said okay after months
and months and months of stuff yes the
utility you can cut off their power but
there's also restrictions on the time of
year you can do it and if there's a
medical issue involved and so forth uh
so they say yeah finally you can shut it
off in july first
that person would then have the option
of the appellate jurisdiction would
would be the supreme court as well so
there's no really change in that it's
just the difference between the body
making the initial decision is now going
to be the department of energy where
before it was the puc but the appellate
uh group was always in
continues to be the supreme court we
don't have any interim court in new
hampshire
so well that that makes sense but i
guess my my question would be
um what we're doing is we're saying that
for rsa 541 we're going to be exempting
the doe from timelines that used to
apply at the puc for these types of
exemptions
and
i guess what i'd like to understand is
why were these timelines in place in the
first place because we're you know we're
we're upending
something that may have been in place
for good reason i understand the idea of
trying to streamline but they probably
had some point well the the
public utilities commission was not on
the timeline
right and and
so we're not so you're trying to shore
up the doe to be consistent with how the
puc
that's correct that's correct we just
want the same treatment that the puck
yeah just the doe does it instead of the
puc
that doesn't that isn't what you're
saying
there is another section on terminations
that is in
1258 okay right
um this deals with everything that
the puc did
that's now been transferred to the
department okay so where the puc
did not have a strict 60-day timeline
the department would not have a strict
60-day timeline we couldn't do it when
we were part of the puc we can't do it
now that we're separated from them it's
just that simple thank you that's great
yeah
clarifies it we move on to three then
david
okay um
three has to do uh with competitive
suppliers
um there are consumer protection
uh provisions in the statute
and in rural
uh
with regard to competitive electric and
gas supply
those consumer
protection
functions were transferred to the
department
but
there's a stray reference to the
commission uh in that statute
so we just want to correct your typo
correct a typo okay hopefully we can
go right through that one okay
and move on to since we've already
discussed four above we go to
so number five has to do with sections
three and four
in uh house bill 1258
and uh in particular this has to do
with that bright red line that
has gotten in the way of uh cooperation
uh among the
two departments and the problem with
that bright red line was that it was
kind of fuzzy
right
and um much wider a line than is really
necessary
um and it
it's just caused all sorts of um
uh problems
so uh we would propose uh eliminating
the language that's currently in the
statute and replacing
that bright red line with the statement
that in adjudicative proceedings
the public utilities and
commission and the department are
subject to a special provision in rsa
541a
and that is the ex parte communication
provision so
if we were actually
in a litigated um
contested case docket
either at the department or at the
commission
the deciders couldn't talk to each other
right so or um
unless it were on the record
and in front of all the other parties so
no secret behind the behind the curtain
communications
in just those
litigated dockets
any other kind of matter we could
communicate with one another like any
other agency can communicate with any
other agency
and this so people understand this fixes
what i've always perceived as kind of a
wrong to say that it's because over the
years the commissioners would sit down
and talk to staff and go over all these
details
that they couldn't and those weren't
considered ex-part-time conversations
but they couldn't sit down and talk to
the uh the litigant who was appealing
the with the utility or a private
citizen because that would be
ex-part-time so this sets it down so if
you're actually going to have uh
official conversations in a judicial
process then they'd be done in what i
referred to earlier as a technical
session where all the parties would be
notified all the parties would be there
and everyone would know what was going
on so this is an improvement from the
what we had existing right and then
understand that the way things are set
up now the commission has its own staff
it has six senior advisors there might
be a financial analyst the commissioners
can still talk to those people they just
can't talk to people at the department
because we're a party in the in the case
and that's what this this bright red
line says the the brighter red line uh
in adjudicative dockets
contested case dockets
okay
okay uh
um
house bill
set up a system where the
the puc and the department could
continue to enforce
the provisions of existing puc rules
as they apply to each agency
right and the reason for allowing us to
continue
to
operate under that same old set of rules
for uh
quite a period of time
was one it
it's an awful lot of work to create new
sets of rules
right
and
two
i think the drafters wanted to make sure
that nothing fell between the cracks
while we were doing that so all of those
regulations still exist
right
was that there was another provision in
rsa541a
that dealt specifically with
organizational rules and
procedural rules
and
that provision in 541a says that when
there's a statute that's passed
that makes your
those rules
not accurate anymore
those expire in just one year
right so those the pucs uh procedural
rules and organizational rules which the
department is still cribbing off of
um
will expire on june 30th
unless something is done
and
that i think would cause
people's heads to explode
if in the midst of all this change and
all this uncertainty everybody suddenly
had to learn another set of procedural
rules
right so what we're asking is is for
uh an exemption
from that provision in 541a so that the
uh commission's procedural rules will
remain in effect and we can continue to
use them until we i believe
i can't hear you maybe that's it maybe
oh okay now it works
okay so that's a good reminder turn your
mic off if you're not speaking that'd be
great okay so my question is this then
with regard to this change
i've spent a lot of time looking at rsa
541 over the years
and i'm familiar with the fact that it
takes close to a year
to
write and get approval for new year new
rules
so from the start of the process until
the rules go into effect is usually a
year
minimum
and it can be longer
so
if this provision wasn't adopted and
those rules that you referred to expire
on june 30th
what rules would be enough would apply
there's a a set of uh procedural rules
that were prepared by the department of
justice that are sort of like a default
set of procedural rules they would just
be very different
right and they they wouldn't really be
tailored to what the puc does
which would just cause more confusion
at this time
so my follow-up would be this change
would be pretty essential then to
allowing the
department to move forward with its
ability to
to use the rules that are in place
absolutely necessary
for that
and of course we're not going to let you
off the hook we will eventually put in
new rules yes don't have to do it by
june 30th right okay okay can we move on
to seven please can i i'm sorry peter go
ahead um
you're asking for an exemption but how
long does that exemption last all right
is this an exemption for a year forever
or what what when does the exemption
i think um
under
the the law it would
it would last
forever
right until we adopt new rules right and
that process is underway i'm the person
tasked with drafting the depart
the department's new procedural rules
and it is a bear
but we're hoping to have that done this
year
and we'll have jackie be the vice
president in charge of making sure they
get the new rules out in a timely manner
there you go
i know they're in a a rule-making
procedure but what i want to ask is how
is this rulemaking
going to affect
the pucs current rules
in other words
my understanding would be the department
of energy is making is in the
rule-making process
how will this affect
puc's rules
well
under 541a if you if you do nothing
but that that's what 541a does it would
cause the public utilities procedural
rules to expire because they're no
longer accurate
right
if
if if you take the action that we're
asking you to do those rules will stay
in effect
and what you're presuming there then i
assume is that when the new rules for
the department of energy come out
there'll be a corresponding set of rules
from the puc that says cancel the
following rules exactly yeah we're
working on the rule making statement
yeah
all right couldn't we have an expiration
of five years i mean the notions are
going to go on forever is is yes five
david if you would five years i'm sure
that we but again we don't make sure it
doesn't fall through the cracks good
point lee thank you
okay uh seven has to do with the
assessment statute this is the way that
the department
uh the commission
and the
office of consumer advocate or funded is
through a assessment on public utilities
and
the
the the job of assessing the utilities
of
figuring out what they uh
what they have to pay invoicing them
collecting the funds etc
um that is all done by the department
now
but there are a number of stray
references in the statute we'll call
them typos
that need to be fixed and that's what
number seven
addresses
so
this is the one that really had me
bothered the doe is going to collect all
the funds and these would also be puc
funds
and i asked you offline that there was a
mention of assessments to utilities
which we have i believe four in this
state
going up
and
perhaps not even being
necessary or not being um
i don't want to say legal but i will say
legal anymore
so
if you do all the assessing are you then
controlling the purse strings
of the puc
which
i i just i i don't understand that and
yes we we do not control the purse
strings so the budget of the puc and of
the oca those are set during the budget
process by the legislature and the
governor right
we would just be collecting the money
and making sure it was in the kitty for
them to use
so
so now
will two agencies be collecting
assessments instead of one
no it's just the department that will
collect the assessment and then
everybody shares in it
so one one
agency collects
i'm not going to belabor it but i will
attorney sheila can you explain to us
how the assessments arrived at like
who's responsible for that piece is it
based on the budgets of the
uh agencies involved or i'm not sure i
can speak to that fully right we
we probably arranged to have somebody
who deals with the budgets to come in
and do that
but um
actually i
i can't even address it we'll have to
have somebody come in and do that for
you but what you're saying is number
seven is basically the
administration of the assessment piece
is going to be over in the doe yeah so
it and it already is these are just
typographical errors right it doesn't
change that how it's arrived at it just
as you said the money goes to and by the
way i was just reminded uh
fill out pin cards please before you
leave you don't have to do them this
second but before you leave please thank
you yeah okay and so we can go on just a
pink because they're speaking that's all
so fred can have the uh information here
correct spelling of david schulack's
yeah all right there you go okay david
there's a section in
house bill 1258
that
changes
i think corrects an oversight
um
by
giving responsibility for rsa 1263b
to the department
but there's one provision
in there
and then
the the drafters at ols just
substituted department for commission
wherever they saw it but there is one
provision in there that actually should
remain public utilities commission
uh because it you know
things have to be done in conformity
with tariffs that are approved by
the commission
right and it's only the commission that
approves tariffs that's
that's one of their powers not the
departments
so it's
also in the vein of
just
i have a quick question about this uh
this one
so this is just in a a correction to
hb 1258 as introduced correct the
there's no correction needed in the
statute that's correct just a correction
to the amendment itself yes exactly
okay uh number nine has to do with
complaints that are filed with the
department
and then referred
to the
public utilities commission for
adjudication right
and
house bill
1258 would insert
by
by a public utility so violations of
statute or ruled by a public utility
could be referred to the public
utilities commission for adjudication
the problem with that insertion
in the amendment
is that
both the department and the public
utilities commission
don't just deal with public utilities
anymore
so we deal with competitive suppliers
etc um
all of whom might be subject to some
adjudication at the public utilities
commission
so the statute is currently we think
correct and and that should come out of
the amendment okay
so number
there are two sections in house bill
1258 that would require
the public utilities commission to
approve something called affiliate
agreements
between public utilities and and their
affiliates
and that's something that the public
utilities commission has never done in
advance
they they might look at a specific
prudence question
uh down the line when some of those
expenses go into rates but
those are not agreements that the public
utilities commission actually approves
um and so we would ask that that
those phrases also come out of uh the
amendment
so this is fixing what was a historic
mistake because it was never done and if
indeed it was looked at it would be
looked at as a rate case if they tried
to bring in costs associated with
number 11
oh
in
yes and in those two sections
it would be the bolded language that
says notwithstanding the requirements of
and and um
uh griffin points out to me that that
would just mean removing sections 11 and
so
number 11 was
one of the matters of discussion between
the public utilities commission
and
the department
there's a
section in
house bill 1258 that would
state that in the
statute governing attachments to polls
that the public utilities commission
would retain
its authority over safety
and a number of other things
and the two agencies looked at that and
we think that the appropriate thing to
do
would be to say
that both the department and the
commission
retain their authority over safety
etc
um rather than specifying one or the
other right
and um there's a good reason for that i
mean the the
provision that this addresses is not a
provision that grants authority or takes
authority away
it's a provision that makes clear
that when utilities enter into
agreements with people who want to
attach to their polls
they can't bargain away the state's
authority to regulate
that's i think what that provision goes
to
and both the
uh department and the
public utilities commission have some
authority
over safety etcetera of those facilities
can you say in in i know we don't have a
department of energy or we didn't
in prior statutes recently
but
can you
specify what safety regulations the
department of energy would have
oversight for because it seems like that
would be regulatory no
well we do have regulatory authority
over the utilities we we have
full plenary jurisdiction over them and
their operations
right the real question is how does and
and so does the puc
and the real question is how does that
get divided up
right
and
that's a much larger
more philosophical question
than this provision addresses
um
we might set the regulations generally
whereas the
public utilities commission adjudicates
them
and enforcement
is that through adjudication or i'm just
trying to figure out again because it's
it's a roles and responsibilities thing
trying to clarify
well it's it's some of both
right so the department has finding
authority for some things right yeah in
some instances we have to go to the
commission to uh have that fine imposed
in some instances we can impose that
fine ourselves it it depends on which
which section of the
the statutes you're looking at
but it's it's quite a matrix and
it sounds like it yeah
so uh
good question um as far as when you're
talking about uh to regulate safety so
would the uh initial jurisdiction be
with the doe and then if there was a
dispute between
whether it's be the utility that owned
the pole or the
company that was wanted to string
fiber optics on it or whatever
and then that would go to the pu to pucs
in the judicial process or they both
have initial jurisdiction because to me
that's kind of confusing one could say
it's okay and one could say it's not
right we have to work that out
the the department is going to
have
say the pipeline safety rules
right
i think the
department will be the one to say that
electrical crossings have to comply with
the national electrical safety code
and and which version
right
um and
the puc will have to interpret along
i i just don't think that it's it's that
specific yet
um and i don't want to be more specific
than that so that nothing falls through
the cracks
until we
make the fine division
okay because this is something that we i
think we're going to address because i
mean i'm looking back at donner over
here as a utility representative you
have
who do you go to when you go to the
department and you go to the puc and
what if they don't agree i mean the the
safety personnel the engineers have been
transferred to doe but there's still
some knowledgeable people at the puc who
could say no no we don't agree that's
not safe enough i mean could be on you
know we got into things like welder
qualifications on pipelines i remember
when randy was there so if there's a
disagreement between the two
it seems like you're kind of putting
everybody in a what do you do next well
we're hoping to clarify a lot of that as
we go through this sort of joint
project on rulemaking
which we're doing in conjunction with
the department of justice
to help us clarify where those dividing
lines will be
okay just it seems like
most of what we've had here is you've
said
go to the doe it appeals to the puc or
go to the doe you appeal to the supreme
court this says you can go to both
and that to me brings up confusion as
far as okay i think i get a better deal
from the puc i'm going to go
say ask them if it's safe or no i think
i get a bit better deal from doe i'll
ask them if it's safe so i think that's
an issue that we need to clean up a
little bit okay
jackie you had a question
yeah i i i guess
maybe my brain is not handling it as
well that we can't talk to each other if
there's
and if there's
conflicting opinions
that the two divisions can't really
discuss with each other why
unless it's in public
and
this is going to take
we just said throughout an arbitrary
number of five five years to work out i
think that's going to be unacceptable
because we see more and more
of what wants to be attached to polls
what's safe to attach to polls
um
yeah you know all kinds of we have more
poll issues in here than we need to
but i i think that
this is going to be an issue
that can't wait for five years while
rulemaking or whatever is going on and
to say that both have jurisdiction
is very interesting because i think then
the legislature could stand up and say
no you guys work it out we'll decide who
has jurisdiction is that a fair
assessment
the legislature can always decide who
has jurisdiction
and um
i don't think that it'll take five years
i mean we've we've begun the rule making
process and we expect to have it done
within 2022.
okay yeah we do expect to do that so so
then what was the extension about
if we're going to be done by this year
there'd be december 31st of this year i
would i'll go with 2022.
why do we need
an extension that could go on
that there was no time limit on so i i
hear what you're saying and i understand
but the the
extension
um is
just for
procedural rules
and for
um
i think organizational rules okay so the
procedural rules of the public utilities
commission would expire
on june 30th
and we're not going to have procedural
roles ready for june 30th
the other rules uh expire when they
expire
which for some of them is
eight years some is six some is five but
we fully expect to have the the
two new sets of rules ready well before
then but the ones you're referring to
with the whether it's six or eight those
are statutory requirements that the
rules expire after so many years
regardless of any reorganization exactly
okay
well this is maybe something that
um we'll have to think about a little
bit the the subcommittee obviously but
maybe it's one of those things that we
want to see how it works and we come
back here if we're here next next term
and say all right let's pick one or the
other because it's not working or maybe
the rules work fine i'm just i'll just
thank you mr shulock for taking this
question since we're on the subject of
rules that are
are being rewritten or being
transferred
doesn't rsa 541 specify that rules need
to be re-evaluated every 10 years
and will that
provision of statute be followed as you
do this new rule making procedure
yes that provision is followed so
house
house bill 2
said that
the
department can enforce those provisions
of the existing puc rules that fall
under its
jurisdiction now until those puc rules
expire
and that's the 10-year reevaluation
that's that's when they expire at the
10-year mark
right and some of those are at eight
years somewhere at
four years somewhere at two years
right so the puc is going to have to
re-evaluate but we're going through the
process now so that's all all of those
rules will be reevaluated within their
10-year
uh period
thank you yeah all right can we move on
to your last point there then twelve
knowing that we may have to revisit this
a little bit okay you're all familiar
with
reggie
right and
the
department of environmental services and
the commission prepares a report
every year
and delivers that to the legislature
regarding reggie
and
the people who would prepare those
reports are now at the department
rather than at the commission
so we're just asking that you specify
that it's the department
of energy that would work with the
department of environmental services to
anyone have any further questions of
oh
yes i'm going back to polls it seems to
me
that
you you have safety rules now that exist
and
if you are going to
make any change to those then that would
probably should be a doe responsibility
but their implementation would be
working through the puc does that split
make sense or am i missing something
well with
with regard to the attachments
uh
this the
the real
split i think would be the
the department does everything
right
unless
the
poll owner and the person who wants to
attach
can't come to an agreement because poll
attachments in the state are primarily
done through agreement
with the utility
by contract
and it's only when
they can't come to an agreement over
those terms that it would be adjudicated
what you know
you adjudicate what the terms would be
and what the costs would be right
um the public utilities commission would
do that under this framework
so follow up
then that would mean
as i hear what you're saying that the
doe should have primary safety
responsibility and the puc is the
i
i don't think it's as easy as that
because
not everything that's done with regard
to safety or storm response is done by
rule right some some of it is done in
adjudication
and
i don't think we're ready at this point
what can only be done by ruling what can
only be done by adjudication
we have to go through and we have to
so would it be safe to say that what
you're asking us is to say let's see how
it works and then maybe we come back in
the future and
specify
a little bit more criteria in the law i
think
for those
for the what we've asked you to do here
i think that change can be made
immediately because it it
it doesn't affect really who has the
safety authority the authority over
safety right that bigger question i
think we should wait and see how things
go
okay thank you very much i have a
question
yeah no
um go ahead yeah and you yeah i think
you were before me i was waiting so
thank you uh is this the sum total of
the requests that you're making
uh i think there are a few things
um
that i'd like to address in the bill
itself or in the um
so and that's where i was going because
i wanted to know if you were prepared to
discuss some of the repeals that are
forced in at the end here i was
particularly concerned with item number
two but you can start wherever you want
in the bill and just know that i'd like
we need to know what we're
item number two
um
relative to open access i believe uh
clifton bilo sitting behind me made a
suggestion
that you repeal everything except for
the first
sentence of that
and the department is okay with that
change
okay
this is at the end under repeals item
20. it's uh page seven line four repeals
but item number two but this is to
repeal everything except the first
sentence of the rsa as it stands that's
his suggestion 374 f3 we don't have an
amendment that does that but that's my
suggestion
so we're all dealing with the same
document here this is the uh as
introduced version of the bill
yes okay and you're talking about
section
that starts on line 25 regulatory
support reference deleted
this is page 7 line 6
and it references the rsa
right okay 374
okay my notes are correct that's what
clifton wanted removed and you're
agreeing with that
uh we're agreeing to repeal of all
except for the first sentence in that
provision
okay so so the first sentence creates
the requirement for open access right
the rest of the provision deals with
things that have already occurred
okay
but the first line is important so
just i just wanted acknowledgement
so will there be an amendment that will
include that first line of rsa 374 f3
four
yes i assume we're going to have
definitely going to have an amendment so
it's uh i
as well okay okay
but
if i may um
yes i think you'd want to pull it out of
the repeal section and it it's would you
say uh amend rsa 374 f3
roman 4. i promised representative plett
i would slow down
and so
that restructuring policy principle
would just read its first line and it
would read roman four open access to
transmission and distribution facilities
non-discriminatory open access to the
electric system for wholesale and retail
transactions should be promoted period
and then there's three or four sentences
that follow that are basically archaic
that are really no longer applicable and
just by saying amen by
restating it
you get rid of that superfluous language
okay
and and i appreciate the department
energy's consideration of that you know
i think that's just the
okay so um
if i may
section two
[Music]
which is on the first page beginning
uh the bolded section
require the
enforcement division of the department
of energy to conduct audits when the
public utilities commission thought that
it ought to
um
the
the department and the commission have
discussed this and it's my understanding
that the commission would like to
withdraw its request
and
h2
the bolded language the bolded language
so
section 2 would no longer be necessary
and the department and the commission
will
work out procedures
in an
mou just a question on that it would it
would seem to me that since the uh
commission is actually doing the
adjudicate process for rate setting
that you know part of what they're
looking at they may go into a docket for
a rate case
and look at something and say
this really doesn't make sense we need
more information we want an audit done
and why wouldn't they be have the
authority to say go audit doe because
you have the auditors why would they
what would they not want that authority
well i i
i think that would be an appropriate
request of of the commission
right
um but this is written broadly enough so
that we don't
nope
neither agency can specify what the
request would actually be
right
that's a perfectly legitimate request
you know the the department
automatically audits uh the test year uh
when it comes to a rate case
um as a support for the staff preparing
the case so that the staff can identify
where the real issues are
and i'm talking the doe would do that
then right so the does it automatically
does that we're still doing all the
audits that we used to do explain the
test you think because a lot of people
might not know what you're referring to
just so it's clear okay we're not all
ex-puc commissioners like clinton
so
are you
utilities rates are forward-looking
right the the utility
is going to try and recover all of its
costs
in in rates in the future but they're
set at a particular point in time
and
the first thing that occurs in that rate
setting process is to determine
what the utilities revenue requirement
is
right how much money do they actually
need to uh conduct from from ratepayers
to conduct their business right
and um
they do that based upon a historic
year
right so they use the past
to look at the future and it's generally
um the year
prior to
the rate case being filed
right so if they file a rate case in
2022 they look at their expenses in 2021
right
and they provide the department with all
the information about those expenses in
and the department goes in and audits
those expenses
to to make you know they
they do things like
do samples and compare receipts
make sure that they match up right
they'll look at
different uh
expense lines and go back to previous
orders and see whether that was
something that was previously
denied for recovery
and if it was
they'll they'll note that to the
department staff and the department
staff will put that on the adjudicative
record for the commission
right but the the audit staff goes
through that test year
to determine
what the revenue requirement of the
utility is that's a starting point for
any rate case and the department will do
that automatically nobody needs to tell
the department to do that because that
is
the backup work for the department's
adjudicative staff
right
go ahead jackie so
if a rate is if a rate case then becomes
controversial
department of energy has done the audit
and said this is what it should be
the company says no this isn't what it
where does the responsibility lie
to
either oversee that audit information
redo that information and hear that
case and
my understanding and a little not clear
who could um
talk to each other about that because it
now becomes
adversarial so you have information
you've provided
that information is not accepted
how do you discuss
how you got your information et cetera
et cetera if you are now an adversarial
party so as it was before
right except the staff was embedded at
the commission
if there is a disagreement over that
revenue requirement it gets litigated
and it gets litigated in front of the
commissioners they get a record prepare
you know presented to them and they they
litigate it that's all done in the
presence of all the parties
that's how it was before it won't change
so what basically i i think what i'm
hearing i don't want to put words in
your mouth but it sounds like the puc is
saying
this
uh
section is not required because an audit
will be done whenever they need one
anyways that's correct and we're going
to
agree to procedures when they actually
see one that they
they think should be done
we're
working on a memorandum of understanding
other changes to the as the bill is
amended
i think that
is it
the chairman
certainly go ahead
thank you thank you for taking my
question paige
for
the bolded language on 20 and 21
uh i thought we would just say that the
affiliate agreements were not approved
by the public utilities commission this
clearly says
oh we did yeah that's the request is to
remove the bold language that that would
be the amendment and it's
thank you for clearing my confusion yeah
okay
yeah
so um there is one more thing i think
when we were here last on page 5 line 23
the public utilities commission
requested
that the commission
also be able to advocate for new
hampshire interests before ferc
and
the department and the puc are still in
discussions with that we've asked the
department of justice to join in on
those discussions
and so
i'm familiar
with my previous experience with newport
the mass attorney general i'm aware of
working with several other states
and
that that's all over the lot but for
instance
vermont there's a department of public
service
in in a separate uh pu public attorney's
commission and
mostly the department of service carries
the load uh but but
sometimes it's both
and the connecticut is connecticut deep
and connecticut uh
forget the analogy there but deep does
most of it but they do both right and so
i'm not sure it's an either or but
frankly you have the staff they don't
have much to have right and and we're
trying to find appropriate language that
for that so
maybe the department in consultation
with
or after consultation with
something like that or
anyhow
for right now i'm leaving that in the
hands of the department of justice to
help us figure out mass masses best deal
d-o-e-r doesn't get involved much but
the puc the dpu does so it depends
anything could work if you work it out
yeah
i would just say that the the issue
there is that you could have a judicial
proceedings that obviously ferc rules
effect on the puc so you'd want to make
sure that they were in communication
with doe
on dealing with ferc on on regional
issues because a lot of these filings
with ferc are done you know they've done
through iso new england as you know and
nepal so we just we need to make sure
that there's a good line of
communication there i don't see that
under the present uh
setup that the puc has the author of has
the staff to do that right but certainly
they're still participating i know for
example one commissioner right now is
down at the neirup meeting so um
they're still going to participate in
that but we've got to make sure that
there is that that
cross-communication because the things
could clearly affect uh ferc rules
clearly affect what goes on in the puc
and it's not just regional only it does
have an impact on how rates are set and
so forth i think the major concern here
is
um
conflicting opinions on what the state's
interests are in the same docket
or in the same proceeding and so we
if we work that out i think everything
my understanding of the intent of this
was to make that type of decision with
the department of energy and not with
the commission
and uh so maybe we need to make sure
that's clarified in here because
it's it's clearly uh two different
things in the past it's been the uh uh
nesco managers have been uh
as you know have been uh from the
commission and uh they've attended all
the regional hearings and so forth and
now that authority has gone over to the
uh to the department of energy so it
would be pretty difficult if they didn't
have the ability to give the position of
the state of new hampshire whether it's
nesco or ferc or whatever because you
kind of have two different opinions so i
think the way that um that's being
looked at currently is that the
um
nesco support function
is at the department but the nesco
manager which is a government governor
appointment
can be anyone
but the support for that position would
be at the department
so
probably no reason why the nesco manager
couldn't be a puc commissioner
right so
right
so
i suppose that
i don't think it's because i don't think
the the nesco situation is
i don't think there's a statute that
addresses that specifically other than
what's right here yeah i would think
that would be very confusing if you had
the puc commissioner as a nesco manager
and then you had a the staff and the
people going to all the meetings and
going down to the you know the i used to
refer them as the burrows for those
endless meetings down there uh working
for the doe that would be kind of a oh
okay i don't have to pay attention to
you you don't work for me or i don't
work for you that's
so i think that was
okay does anyone have any other
questions uh and i open this up to
anybody that wants fred
yes who is drafting the additional
changes to hp 1258 for representative
sure
thank you for volunteering david yeah
obviously it's got to go through well
ols but we want to start with language
to them right okay
happy to do that
and uh again i'll open this up to
anybody now that might have questions of
the representatives from doe uh i know
donna you presented some comments did
you want to uh
uh
yeah you have to use a mic though okay
thank you um i just wanted to say that
their explanation today um clarified any
of the remaining questions that we had
and in particular what we had
the biggest concern was the crossing
license and we had chatted with them
about that in advance so we knew that
they were going to be coming in and
clarifying and today's clarification
covers everything so unless something
new comes up i'm going to take these
notes back but i think for now we're
good
great so we give you the speaker of the
day award thank you well while we're on
the crossing i just want to um clarify
that what we're hoping to do
is to
bring everybody into the tent on
crossings so everybody has to get a a
license right no exemptions
right
but that the
rigors of getting that license would
depend on what kind of crossing it was
so if it is a
non-electrical wire
going across
two existing poles on a crossing
right
that review that that application in
that review might be less stringent than
a review for new polls on a new crossing
right so that everything
sort of matches you know in terms of how
burdensome the uh the review needs to be
right
because i you know i know people people
were concerned with you know
if they had to change
just a signal wire at the top of their
poles
they would have to go through a full
adjudication to do that
with
an incredibly long application to do
that and it's not really necessary
for a signal wire at the top of two
existing poles because it doesn't really
affect anything
and and
uh we would try to develop rules and
applications that that matched the type
of crossing
um and of course the public
and um any representative who wanted to
and the utilities would all be able to
participate in that rulemaking
and have an effect on that
and i was just going to add that that is
really the process where we believe that
we would be putting our energies as well
thank you
just a final thing as i'm looking back
at some of my notes from the previous
one so the puc has now uh agreed that
they don't need to be able to demand
audits because they'll take place
whenever they're necessary and
the poll attachments there on board with
what you've presented as well yes okay
thank you mr chairman
my question is on page two at the bottom
uh i had some things highlighted in here
page two of the bill 1258
um
at the bottom
and it's line 36. we're removing that
orders final orders that come out from
the commission have to
include the positions of each party on
each issue
and i just have a question there because
i think those final orders in many cases
are
you know a nod to transparency in the
state in terms of how the parties in in
a proceeding
um
you know how they make their cases in
terms of whatever's coming out in those
paperwork wise people might not want to
have to present the positions of the
parties but transparency wise i think
that's why it's in the statute so i wish
you could speak to that
so this
change was made at the request of the
public utilities commission
not
by the department
but i would note that
it doesn't forbid them
from putting in the positions of the
parties in an appropriate order just
doesn't require it just doesn't require
it so
um you know there are some sort of
smaller orders
where it would be nice just to be able
to do them with dispatch
right um rather than going through them
well yeah that also may add to that you
when you go to the website uh where the
let's say the final order is there
you're going to see the positions of all
the parties this is a summarized version
yeah that's written by a lawyer at the
at the puc and kind of interpreting what
the party's position was the whole
position in maybe 50 60 pages for every
detail you want is right there on the
same website and it's simply a matter of
just clicking on that and you can get
the whole thing this this position is a
summary done by the staff of the puc so
you know it's there's some value to it
but it's not uh it's not the same as
going back and reading the actual
position which is very accessible for
people okay and i saw somebody over here
jackie do you have a question was it lee
yeah i had i had a comment and a
question the comment was one on a minor
comment was on language of confidential
and i
maybe legally there's a difference
between proprietary and confidential
i would rather see conf proprietary
inserted in those places
if the department of energy does not
want
or does not believe that an audit needs
to take place and the puc say believes
a more accurate decision they need an
audit
who prevails or how does that get worse
is that just a thing you work out
between yourselves and say okay we'll do
it or no we're not gonna and that's it
i i just wondered how that
one the public utilities commission
has the statutory authority to conduct
an audit
right so if it wants an audit conducted
it can order one
right
but
then the next question is when should
the department do that
oftentimes it should be the department
the problem with the language that's
before you is that it's very broad
right and it doesn't give anybody
any real understanding of what audits
the public utilities commission might be
requiring of the department
right
and
we feel confident that we'll be able to
work
out an agreement and standard operating
give the
commission
and everyone the assurance that they
need that audits that need to be
conducted will be conducted
it's actually hard to imagine what
what else they would require that we're
not already doing
and if
somehow the situation arose that the
department felt it wasn't necessary or
didn't have the staffing at that time
because of other issues the puc still
has a budget for this and they could go
outside and hire a private consulting
firm to do this i assume well
right the puc has a
budget
for consultants which could be an audit
right um but that's quite small the
the
normal way to charge that would be by
special assessment on the utility being
audited
right so that
it's just that utility that pays for the
audit but they would have the option of
doing that as my point yeah both both
the public utilities commission and the
department have the option of doing that
okay thank you
fred glenn this is a question for the
subcommittee chairman and the full
committee chairman uh when is it
necessary to have an amendment to be
able to run through ols to keep us on
schedule i'll defer to uh mr votes on
that one yeah let's uh defer that
question until we have completely
illuminated all the issues with regard
to the content of the amendment then
i'll speak to the
to the timing of the amendment
so
clifton did you want to speak
i i do have um
an issue of concern that
the department might also respond to um
would you like me to go ahead and
address that now yes definitely okay um
and i'm i do have two separate cards
here i was speaking on that
restructuring statute issue on behalf of
the community power coalition in new
hampshire on this issue i'm speaking on
behalf of a private entity
called one court street associates of
which i'm a partner
and it concerns section 10 of the bill
that was discussed earlier about um
[Music]
investigation
uh of complaints excuse me could you
give us the page number oh on page four
and i spoke i spoke with mr shulock
about this a little bit uh before you
started and so he may have a view on
this um
but um
basically uh under the pucs traditional
rules
if there's a complaint and i should say
that five years ago one court street
associates filed a complaint
as a customer of liberty utilities that
liberty utilities was failing to
meet a statutory requirement a rules
requirement and also tariff issues
um
and
and um
they they responded and um
the long and short of that is it's we've
been in limbo for four years on that
case um
the department or the former puc staff
never completed its independent
investigation
um
[Music]
the long and short of that is that
liberty proposed sort of a compromise
solution that would require agreement by
the state of new hampshire and the city
of lebanon and i i don't can't represent
the city in this matter because i have a
you know a private interest in the
matter and and the city manager said he
was not interested in in doing what
uh liberty utilities proposed
um and so we didn't even go to the state
of new hampshire because basically would
have the state and the city and a couple
other private parties assume
responsibility for a piece of equipment
that um that houses the point of
interconnection for about five or six
different um retail services or our
retail customers where they uh
it's the point of interconnection
between
liberties uh
load side bus bar of their transformer
and where these different businesses
including the state of new hampshire and
the city of new lebanon take power uh um
inside this piece of equipment that that
the entity that originally paid for it
no longer exists um because they were
required to pay for it as an upgrade for
their own interconnection uh uh for for
retail service so the long and short of
that is no nobody owns
liberty's disclaiming ownership of the
property even though it houses the piece
of interconnection so so the problem is
when this law went into effect
it seems to override the procedural
rules which basically say after the
independent investigation if there isn't
sort of a resolution of the matter
that's satisfactory uh the customer can
request a hearing by the commission to
resolve the matter through an
adjudication um
and right now with this new law saying
it's it's in effect saying only the
department can bring the proceeding over
to the puc
so if we're yeah and and the commission
just a week ago asked for status update
they directed that to the department of
energy which was the responsible party
for investigating the complaint i we
because of the change in the law we
don't really have any say in that status
update i i don't think i don't know
but it was directed to the department um
and and so the concern is
if for instance the parts department
said you know we'll we'll try to work
this out you can close the case
and i don't know what it means that a
case that was started five years ago you
know if if the new law suddenly means
we've we've voided our due process
rights in in that proceeding but my
concern is if if a party isn't satisfied
with the disposition of a complaint by
the department they would do not appear
to have any recourse
to the puc to adjudicate the matter
and it was commented earlier that in a
complaint i think representative kelly
pitts was you know thinking about a
shutoff type situation
that if if the customer is not satisfied
well they could appeal the department's
decision to the supreme court but the
problem is the department doesn't have
the requirement to
adjudicate the issue in the first place
nor to write a sort of findings of fact
and you know
reasoning of the reasoning or you know
rulings on the legal questions the puc
is perfectly well suited to do exactly
that
and so i think you know my concern is
due process for anybody who has a
complaint that i don't think the supreme
court will be interested in trying to
resolve a matter when there is not a
record of the type that the puc produces
you you don't have i mean the department
might do that they might try to write
something up that looks like okay we've
we've we've this is our opinion on how
this should be resolved but it's it's
not an actual
adjudication you haven't had your day in
court so to speak so it's hard to i
think it would be very difficult to
appeal that kind of decision to the
supreme court so so i i and and um i
think mr schlock was sort of mentioned
that he was aware that the department's
aware of this sort of
issue and and and so uh he said you know
maybe they'd consider you know they
consider some language
and i've just sort of drafted out
something and i'll just throw it out for
your consideration what if and in
section 10 you added a sentence at the
end that read something like this if the
party bringing the complaint
is unsatisfied
with the disposition of the complaint by
the department of energy they may
request a hearing before the commission
to resolve the matter through an
adjudicated proceeding and then both the
parties the utility
and and the customer
can have sort of their day um in which
then there's a record established i mean
there's a huge amount of filings already
in the case
you know to to substantiate our claim
and of course liberty responded you know
they kind of know that this is a a
problem as well and they tried to do a
compromise which would have been okay
with us but it wasn't okay with other
parties that would have to assume
response collective responsibility for a
piece of equipment that other parties
didn't think they wanted to assume
because it sure looks like a part of the
distribution system because
you know it includes stuff that liberty
owns it in it and this stuff is rusting
so that's you know our local electrical
inspection said there's an electrical
hazard here because some of this stuff
could is rusting and it could collapse
and cause everyone to lose service but
nobody's willing to take responsibility
for it you know it's not something we
it's not on our property we never paid
for it you know it serves a whole bunch
of other customers it's like why should
we assume responsibility for this piece
of equipment so i mean that's the nature
of the problem um
so i'm sorry to share the specifics of
our case but it illustrates
um it's just a case in point is how do
you get due process
david you want to address that so
with regard to the specifics of the case
i haven't reviewed the docket but it
sounds like i would stay away from the
specifics in the case here just for
example
it does sound like a docket was opened
um and that the public utilities
commission has retained jurisdiction
over it because they haven't closed or
transferred the docket
to the department
so
one we would have to look at the
specifics of those and i can't do that
here right then
secondly
that there are some issues related to
how complaints would be referred right
or um
i i guess more appropriately stated
dismissed if the department were to find
that there were no basis for the
complaint
right
and where
i'd be happy to take this language back
to the department and to the public
utilities commission to have it vetted
but i i can't agree to it here yeah
that's fine that was what i was going to
suggest i think that um
i know there are other departments like
des that issues rulings and those the uh
the appellate uh
organization is the supreme court i'm
not just sure if the department of
energy is set up because it sounds like
a lot of the rulings are going to be
appealed through the puc
so maybe that's the way we should do it
on this case there but taking the
language back and getting back to us
would be certainly appreciate i think i
think there's some merit and what was uh
what clifton said there because you kind
of leave people with no place to go
and you know if they say no
and there's not even a real adjudicative
process how do you appeal that to the
supreme court because you have no
documentations to bring to the court to
appeal
well
that's if we didn't produce
documentation right so we haven't gone
through this yet
but um i do
view this as at least
partly judicial when we're deciding
there's no merit to your case and we
would have to we would have to issue
something jackie go ahead
as being one of the quote-unquote
normal people that i heard
bandied around today what happens or
and because i don't have the
organization down pat does the consumer
advocate can this consumer advocate
mediate
for a
consumer
and i'm not talking about a large
conglomerate i'm talking about me the
normal citizen because that's still an
office
right and then if i look at the or if i
think about the organization right now
i'm thinking of the organization as
doe
puc a consumer advocate is supposed to
stand alone where does all this meld
together
and
can that happen there is a consumer
division i am assuming in your
where does the consumer advocate come in
so
there is the consumer office of the
consumer advocate and then there's the
consumer division within the department
right used to be the consumer division
of the puc okay
and their functions have remained the
same
so
the office of consumer advocate
represents the interests of residential
rate payers generally
not any individual rate payer right so
were you to go to the office of consumer
advocate and say i'm having
problems paying my electric bill can you
help me get a payment plan the consumer
advocate would send you to our consumer
division
right
um at the department and the department
would help you communicate with your
utility
would tell you what
you know
sort of protections you have in the
situation and what you don't have in the
situation what protections the utility
has in the situation
and would work with you in a discussion
with the utility to to get you a payment
particular decision whatever it may be
if it's not satisfactory
to the consumer is then my understanding
the way the bill stands now the consumer
cannot take that
to an adjudicative
position to the puc
that's correct so if the consumer were
unhappy in that situation
the consumer could file a formal
complaint
that would then be investigated to
determine whether by the department
right
um
to determine whether there was a
an adequate basis to it to send it to
adjudication at the puc and that would
original decision
yes the department of energy
okay thank you
just just so i'm clear on that though
that wouldn't be necessarily the same i
mean i'll just use names so they go to
them they call amanda i have a complaint
i've got to work out something with the
by utility and they come to some what
they think is a resolution the complaint
and says i'm not satisfied with this so
i want to fall file a formal complaint
the formal complaint doesn't go back to
the same people that tried to work out
the thing it would go to a higher up
level on the doe
okay
so
the original issue let's say it's the
consumer affairs division they make a
decision this is this is an equitable
resolution so if the complaint says no
it's not right i want to file a formal
complaint who do they go to okay so
say it's something like
my telephone company is charging me
for two basic telephone lines when i
only have one
okay right
um and so
basic being the key word because if
there's anything other than that the puc
has no authority to regulate or the or
the department right
so um
so that would come to our consumer
services division they would work with
you
right
if
they
agreed
with the utility
that it were appropriate to charge you
for two lines
they would tell you that
if you were dissatisfied with that
you would file
um and
normally
you'd be working with one of the staff
representatives
within that division right that staff
representative would be supervised
by
the
director of the consumer services
division who is supervised by the
director of the regulat the
policies and programs division who is
supervised by
the
assistant commissioner and the
if you were dissatisfied with that
decision you would file a complaint that
complaint would be reviewed by the legal
division
and
by
probably the director of the consumer
yes so it's the same department likely
different individuals
okay but but that gets us back to what
the clifton had brought up and you're
going to take that back and look at it
so the the individual under his wording
would then have the option to file with
the puc and say open an adjudicative
process on this but we're not saying you
agree with that but you're going to look
anybody else peter
this is not
this is not a comment about the bill
but it kind of resonates with what
jackie was talking about for trying to
figure out
where everything belongs
um i sent
i sent you michael a list of ten
questions that really had to do with
giving us more thorough information
about exactly how this reorganization
looks
what got transferred who's who has the
authority who has the regulatory
authority
and i i
posted a bunch of questions relating to
the the presentation we got back in may
by the department of energy about how
they expect things to shuffle around
um
i i would hope that and this is not just
for this this subcommittee i think our
whole committee should get a more
thorough briefing in what has happened
what the orc sharks look like who's
responsible
for example what about the sec where
does that fit into this whole thing like
jackie was saying the consumer
advocate where does that fit in who they
report to uh
what kind of independence is there
between each each entity
all these are questions that we never
had a chance to discuss
so i'd like to see us at some point give
the whole committee a more thorough
review
of not just this bill and the amendments
but basically what the new organization
looks like
as you all probably know most most
democrats in the past have always
supported a department of energy because
we thought it was important to have
those consolidated efforts made
however right now a lot of things are
just up in flux
and we just don't know
where everything is who's responsible
for it and i think it would be very
useful if the department could provide
us with some of that information and i
can give you the yeah
just for a copy of what peter said to me
i think what he said is right on point
and it's a little above this so i'll
defer to the chairman on this but i
think that one of the issues we run into
constantly on this committee is people
come up to us and ask us questions
because and they want yes or no answers
because if you give them anything that
lasts more than 30 seconds they say i
have no idea what the hell you're
talking about so we really need to be
able to address some of the questions he
uh addressed here so
i will leave that to the chairman to
make that decision i have one more thing
to add if i may
um
the way i look at it i i agree with you
that the org chart i mean it it's pretty
the york chart they gave us is pretty
clear to me i would love to have them
come back and tell us if that's how it's
being implemented and also if all the
roles that they needed to fill are all
filled and all that i'd like to know how
it's operating now
but i think my concern
from looking through eight from reading
through hb2's language on the
enactment of the doe to now
is that
the public utilities commission as an
entity and a regulatory body was very
well established and very well defined
and in statute in terms of its
authorities its requirements what it
would be responsible for although we
have the org chart that breaks down
what will be happening in the department
of energy i think that the doe
has
a less defined
operating
charge in terms of statute and so
in some cases
i think that's partly why you're having
that request for edits here is that you
if you put both names in a place and say
well now we're both going to straddle
that responsibility
but you don't have the statutory
obligations that are written
it makes it really confusing to sort of
keep up with
are all the bases still covered
are we still
are we still operating in an environment
where we get as much out of our
regulatory procedures as we did in the
past and i think we're trying to get
some understanding of that to make sure
that
that we're not okaying bills that are
allowing us to go to
a situation where we have an agency that
has the
has the authority or the power
but not the responsibility
because a lot of the responsibility
pieces for the public utilities
commission were highly defined
how they operated was highly defined
um and i and i think even something as
simple as having your own investigators
that you operate with
openly
versus having investigators that belong
to a department that you are now housed
within
uh can influence how the investigations
go and and even though i'm not i'm not
saying that will happen
i'm saying it's um
it's a less
efficacious
uh setup to have uh the people that are
providing you with the information of
how to look at a case come from
an agency that's not governed by those
same regulatory requirements
i'd like to jump in here and
state that
i agree
that
having a
presentation by the department to the
full committee
to
explain exactly
who does what
when and how
would be very useful
and we will try to set that up it may
not be possible to do it between now and
may 26th when our official session year
ends
by next fall
at the latest we'll arrange that with
the department and have a
a presentation have a
essentially a work session with the
committee to
fully understand just how the department
of energy and the public utilities
commission are functioning these days i
have to leave at 12 so i'd like to
address the
procedural issues that we face with this
subcommittee going forward
it is my intention
to
exec the remaining stne bills on
february 28th
and march 1st
therefore any amendment that's going to
be attached to this bill 1258
needs to be completed
by friday
february 25th
now i assume this committee would like
to the subcommittee would like to meet
and discuss that amendment
before it's
judged by the committee so i would
suggest that this subcommittee may want
to meet again
on february 22nd 23rd
24th
with an amendment in hand that it can
review and make changes to so that a
final amendment could be produced by the
25th
i committee we have to book two two two
two two what do you think
fred come on
if anybody should know
the attractiveness of that idea it
should be you yeah
yeah i i think does that work let's
everyone please check your calendars as
well as we like the people from d.o.e
here again and anybody else so uh if uh
that tuesday the 22nd does that give
everybody does that give the doe enough
time to make the changes that we've
discussed here
one more step in that is we have to have
language from the doe to submit through
ols and even if we're submitting
language they still have to review it
make sure they're okay with it so that's
i'm suggesting that that work possibly
could be done
this week
so that when you come in on the 22nd
you'll have an amendment to evaluate
and you can make changes to it and then
resubmit it to ols ask ols by wednesday
or thursday or friday of that week for a
complete final amendment okay so i would
be giving
either you or representative harrington
language to give to ols this week
ols would work on preparing something i
understand 21st is a holiday too so okay
that's monday of that week so i don't
know should we push that to uh instead
of that lyrical day should we go to the
next one michael i i think i can
probably have language
ready by wednesday nope no time pressure
yeah
yeah okay well if you can have that to
als by wednesday they should be able to
get it to us by the 22nd or by friday i
would think okay so that would work so
why don't we tentatively look for you
submitting by the 16th
and uh
als getting it to us by the 18th and
then
that will okay we'll we'll circulate it
around to the whole committee and we'll
meet here at
um
i know peter would suggest 10 o'clock
again because he doesn't like nine so if
not 10 works for everybody can we
schedule that michael
excuse me
can i just uh mention that uh the week
of the 28th of february is school
and uh
i won't be here for that whole week
since now
representative callie pitts told me
that the
previous week was school vacation week
is that not true it depends on the town
because a lot of towns don't do it the
previous week because it matches
massachusetts and we used to have kids
that meant you spent a lot more money
traveling if you did it on a
okay well anyway i i will be gone from
the 27th to the 5th of march
that last week
but you know
you will not be able to attend exec
sessions on the 28th and the first of
march
so you'll have to arrange for a
substitute for yourself okay
it sounds like we have a plan going
forward it just 10 o'clock work for the
subcommittee members then 10 o'clock on
except i've got sun committee down
well we all made it here after the super
bowl so i mean i don't know how much you
celebrate for george washington's
birthday lee but i didn't think it was a
[Music]
uh yes uh with that i will adjourn the
subcommittee hearing on hb 1258. thank
well michael the the chairman just said
he wants to exec everything on the 28th
and the first so
i think it's fairly close because you
we're going to have crossover day coming
you